where the heck does Consciousness happen
in what we understand about the brain
timing-wise
I mean this connects to conscious will
to our experience of free will yeah
there is this period of time and it's
depending on the situation and the
behavior
um it can be anywhere from it's
essentially half a second there's 200
milliseconds I actually don't know I was
going to compare it to the timing of
thinking film and sound I don't know if
you know this yeah and I know this very
well you do the the the film and sound
yeah like yes what how the time how the
timing has to work so that we conscious
so that our experiences of it happening
at the same time
let me just let me just sit sit in the
in the Silence of it there's been so
much pain on this one point
we have no idea so I mean I yeah I did a
lot of algorithms on automatic
synchronization of audio and video and
all these kinds of things you know I
know this well uh there's a lot of
Science and there's a lot of differences
but it's about
and people claim it's about 100
milliseconds you can't tell the
difference but it's much more like 30 to
50 milliseconds okay and it it Dr you
can go nuts trying to see if something
is in sync or not yes is it in sync or
not well also am I out of sync right now
brain is constantly making adjustments
yeah and so it can shift for you while
you're doing that which is probably part
of the thing that's driving you crazy
um okay so I'll start with binding
processes and then I'll just give a
couple examples
um so yes there's this window
um where your brain is
essentially putting all the information
together to deliver you a present moment
experience that is most useful for you
to navigate the world
um
so as I said and you know I use this
example of tennis in my book so the
sights and sounds are coming at us at
different rates
um it takes longer for a sensation in my
hand when I hit the ball with the racket
to travel to my brain than it does for
the light waves to hit my retina and get
processed by the brain so all these
these signals are coming in at different
times our brains go through this process
of binding to basically weave it all
together so that our our conscious
experience of that is of seeing hearing
and feeling the ball hit the racket all
at the same time that's obviously most
useful to us
binding is is mostly about timing it can
be about other things but I was just
talking to David Eagleman who was
talking about a very simple experiment
actually and this kind of shows how your
brain is basically always interacting
with the outside world and always making
adjustments to make its best guess about
the most useful present moment
experience to deliver
so this is a very simple experiment this
is from many many years ago
um and David David Eagleman was was
involved in this research where they had
participants hit a button and that
button caused a flash of light and
so our brains through binding the brain
it notices is is able to
kind of calibrate the experience you
have because the brain is aware that it
is its own hand that is causing the
light to flash that there's this cause
and effect going on and so you
have this experience of pushing the
button that causes the flash of Light
which is true and the light flashes
you can start to introduce longer pauses
starting with 20 milliseconds 30
milliseconds going up to I think 100
maybe even 200 milliseconds where if you
do it gradually since your brain is
making the adjustment
um you can introduce a delay I think
it's up to 200 milliseconds if you do it
gradually you will still have the
experience even though there's now a
delay between when you hit the button
and the light flashes you will still
have the exact same experience you had
initially which is that the light
flashes right when you push the button
in your experience nothing is changing
but then so they they gradually give a
delay
you've acclimated to that because it was
done gradually if they then go back to
the original instantaneous flash your
brain doesn't have time to make the
adjustment
and you have the experience that the
light flashed before you hit the button
and that is your true experience it's
not like you're confused but that is
your brain didn't have time to to make
that adjustment you think you're in the
same environment you're pushing the
button it makes the light flash it's
kind of
calibrating all the time but then the
the participants are suddenly saying oh
wait that was so weird the light flashed
before I hit the button
and so these types that's crazy they
built a
um Rochambeau rock paper scissors
computer game that was unbeatable based
on this glitch that you can present in
in binding by training someone if you
introduce a delay slowly enough then the
computer can get the information
before it responds but you still have
the experience that you're both
throwing out your rock or paper scissors
at the same time but in actuality the
computer
saw your choice
before it makes its choice and it's in
this window of milliseconds where you
don't notice it
so that starts to help you build up an
intuition that this conscious experience
is an illusion constructed by the brain
after uh conscious will conscious will
yeah and and just in general that that
Consciousness is not the thing that we
feel it is which is driving the behavior
that is actually at the tail end of it
and so a lot of decision-making
processes and they're studies that are
more controversial and I don't usually
um like to cite them although if you
want to talk about them we can they're
super interesting and into intuition
shattering but they're they're now
studies specifically about free will to
see if there are markers at the level of
the brain they can see what decision
you're going to make and when you make
that decision and I think this the
Neuroscience inevitably is just going to
get better and so
part of the reason I'm so passionate
about this I mean there's there's the
science and there's just the Curiosity
that that drives me of wanting to
understand how the universe works but I
actually see a lot of the Neuroscience
presenting us with truths that are going
to be difficult for us to accept
and I actually think there are really
positive ways to view these truths that
we're uncovering and even though they
can be initially kind of jarring and
even destabilizing and creepy I think
ultimately
there's actually a lot
it can have a positive effect on human
psychology and a whole range of things
that I and others have have experienced
and that I think it's important for us
to talk about because
you can't hide from the truth especially
in science right like it just it will
reveal itself and if this is true I
think not only
for better understanding the universe
than nature which is kind of my my
primary passion
um it's important for us to
absorb these facts and realize that they
don't it doesn't necessarily take away
the things from us that we fear
um I you know I've heard people say this
is talked about the common common point
to make or question to ask a scientist
can you still
you know enjoy chocolate if you're a
molecular biologist and
um is in a molecular biologist that
would be the one who would understand
how we experience chocolate
yeah but anyway the point stance if
you're focused on the the details of the
you know the underlying nature of
reality does that take
the joy and the pleasure and for lack of
a better word spirituality out of our
experience as human beings and I
actually think
um for these Illusions like Free Will
and self the reverse is true I actually
think they can give us
their reasons and bases for
feeling more connected to each other and
to the universe for Spiritual
experiences for
um
even just on a more basic level for
increasing our well-being just in terms
of our psychology of lowering rates of
depression and anxiety and
um actually I think these realizations
can be extremely helpful to people